[Music]
and tonight we'll see what's making the
headlines with the journalist and author
christine patterson and the columnist at
the article ally mirage a very good
evening to both of you we'll chat in a
moment after we've had a look at some of
those front pages for you starting with
the sunday telegraph ahead of next
week's budget announcement the telegraph
reports chancellor rishi sunak is set to
give the nhs around 5 billion pounds to
fund new hospitals and a digital
overhaul
the sunday express also leads on the
anticipated budget claiming mr sunak
will focus on border security and what
the chancellor has labeled a skills
revolution
the observer says ministers are actively
considering introducing plan b covered
restrictions in response to a vortex of
pressures facing the nhs
on the front of the sunday times is an
in-depth investigation into a british
soldier's conduct in kenya where a sex
worker was killed in 2012.
the sunday people reveals that in the
last year 51 mps called the police over
violence and threats towards themselves
their staff or their families
while the sunday mirror reports that
with just days to go ahead of the cop 26
climate summit the prime minister flew 1
200 miles on a private jet in just two
weeks
and the star goes with the headline dry
your pies mate amid claims mince pies
could be the latest product to fall
victim
to supply chain issues
and i'm joined tonight by christina
patterson and ali mirage so a couple of
things to talk about we'll talk about
the budget and then we'll talk about
covid christina why don't you uh start
things off for us front of the sunday
express lots of talk in the papers about
what we can expect in the budget on
wednesday the express saying that it's
going to be a greater britain border
security and a skills revolution at the
heart of the plan
yes well good old express it always
manages to find something sort of
patriotic and hopeful to say about every
single headline
um
yes there's a skills revolution i think
everything is always called a revolution
isn't it when a budget is announced and
border security
also sounds very let's please the red
wall-ish though um pretty patel doesn't
seem to be doing a terribly good job on
that front it was very interesting this
week that in fact it was actually
upsetting when sanji javid said that um
the number of deaths which had been you
know between 150 and 200 a day this week
were mercifully low but you know you get
20 people coming over in a boat from
france and that is you know a horrifying
number and something must be done but i
think this is the good bit of it for
rishi soon i call brand rishi as the
times insists on calling him because
this is when he gets to announce his
spending and have toddlers crawling
around number 11 and saying that you
know he's uh he's starting family helps
and all the rest of it the bad bit will
be afterwards when people realize a what
he hasn't spent money on on and b what
he's slashing and there's going to be an
awful lot of slashing coming up
uh ali do you share that sort of fairly
pessimistic view
well i do think that uh rishi sunak has
got a very narrow landing strip on which
to um uh navigate the situation on the
one hand
he's uh got various cabinet ministers
trumping at the bit for more money he's
got michael govind post uh in the new
department for leveling up he's also got
a new education secretary nadine zahawi
who are both pushing for increased
allocations to their budgets and he's
also very well aware of the fact that
he's got 400 billion of borrowing that's
been spent on the covid pandemic 2
trillion of public debt and the spectra
of rising inflation inflation already
above three percent predicted to go
above five percent in q1 next year and
now um murmuring is coming out of the
bank of england that interest rate rises
could be on the horizon as early as
november and that means for the
chancellor a 1 increase in interest
rates means 25 billion extra in interest
payments on government borrowing so he's
got a very difficult job and he works
for a boss um who we know
likes to have his cake and eat it who's
not really very focused on spending
issues so i don't think rishi sunak's
got an easy job to do i think it's
fraught with political difficulties for
him personally and we know that he's an
ambitious guy he's also a very smart and
clever guy who would like to probably
end up in number 10 himself so it's not
an easy situation for him to manage and
i think that we'll have to wait and see
what he does but it's not just a budget
it's also a three-year spending review
and i think everyone's going to be
watching that very very closely
uh yeah i see in the last few moments uh
we've just seen inside the sun wishi
sunak has written an article there
saying this week's budget and spending
review will set out a plan to deliver
the people's priorities support business
help our recovery ease pressures on the
cost of living but also to strengthen
the public finances so we can have a
stronger economy for the british people
at the angle the sunday telegraph is
going with christina is that the
chancellor is to spend billions to
digitize the nhs many nhs trusts still
using uh files and paper uh according to
the to the to the telegraph and actually
one thing um well one of the many things
i guess that that was a success in the
rollout of the vaccine initially was
that we managed to get things digitized
and up and running very quickly didn't
we
yes that was a huge nhs success and it
was you know slightly annoying that the
government kept claiming credit for it
because it was the nhs who did that and
who did as the phrase goes rather
irritatingly goes roll it out very
successfully i must say i think most of
us have seen big improvements on this
front in recent years you know i'm i
remember the first time i got cancer
they lost everything they lost um you
know all the results disappeared and i
went off to operate an operation and the
surgeon opened an envelope which was
meant to be a mammogram and turned out
to be an x-ray of an ankle so i do think
that things have improved since then and
now that we get texted by our gp surgery
and we get uh you know called for a flu
jab and things like that there certainly
is progress but it was alarming to read
in this telegraph piece that something
like one in ten trusts are still
paper-based which seems pretty
extraordinary in 2021 so this sounds
like a good idea but in terms of the
overall nhs budget it's going to be a
kind of drop in the ocean and yet again
there's mention in this piece about the
48 hospitals that boris johnson has
claimed that the tories will build well
we know that they've been everyone has
been told to call a new wing of a
hospital a new hospital so i think we
don't need to doubt that there will be
sort of orwellian twists to to make sure
that they pretend that they have met
their targets and kept their promises
which
seems unlikely given the massive
backlogs a massive waiting list that's
built up ali a quick thought on this
before we move on to covid
well look i actually think that the the
tories are out flanking labor on the nhs
now i mean what are you going to do if
you're on the left i mean the tories are
splashing money at the nhs the 1.25
percent increase in national insurance
which is going to be
uh
increasing the allocation to the nhs by
12 billion a year for the next three
years to deal with this massive nhs
backlog of five million people on
waiting lists which side of javits only
said a few weeks ago could rise to 30
million is a big big commitment my
biggest fear is that that money does not
get reallocated in three years time to
social care which is what it's meant for
this uh story is saying that five
billion is going to be spent on the
capital budget which includes digitizing
digitization uh as christina alluded to
and i think that's all very welcome but
it also says that tory mps are very
worried and putting pressure on sadhu
javid to make sure that the nhs also
does reform and said your job has set up
a new delivery unit to ensure that that
happens
okay well let's stay with the nhs but in
terms of kovid the front of the sunday
times christina the health secretary is
going to make nhs staff have uh have
both jabs what do you think about this
is is that fair
i think it is the right decision in in
many countries in europe and around the
world
vaccinations have been made mandatory
for all healthcare staff this has
already happened in the social care
sector albeit very recently and albeit
too late for quite a lot of residents
the problem of course is that there do
remain some people who've been so
effectively brainwashed by facebook
propaganda and you know
social media and so on that they still
believe sincerely that vaccines are
unsafe and are still refusing to be
vaccinated and the nhs has much better
work protection rights for its employees
so it's not going to be able to fire the
people who refuse to have vaccinations
it will probably have to move them to
so-called back room roles and that will
create
you know significant problems on the
wards in terms of staffing and so on but
certainly people who have not been
vaccinated should not be working with
people with patients who are vulnerable
so i do think it's the right decision
does it surprise you ali that there are
still a significant number of people
working in the nhs who are refusing to
get chat
it does surprise me and i do think it's
very unfortunate the problem is there's
a structural issue with labour shortages
not only in the nhs but also in the
social care sector there's a shortage of
about 30 000 nurses in the nhs so this
policy is going to
uh increase pressure on that very issue
in terms of supply of staff however i do
believe that it is the right thing to do
i do think it's the the entry price if
you like for uh being in a frontline
professional you're working with people
who in many cases are very vulnerable so
i think unfortunately for those people
who are still resisting it is a price
that needs to be paid and i think the
quicker we can all get on and do this
the better but i do understand that it
is going to cause some
supply shortages and headaches for the
government
in imposing it
okay and uh finally the front of the
observer staying with uh kovit i wonder
christina this is slightly written up uh
the headline ministers pave way to bring
in tough plan b covid rules is the
headline uh the story actually is that
the uk health security agency uh spoke
to local authorities last week to get
their level of support for the immediate
rollout of the winter plan plan b so
it's sort of a gauging opinion really
more than anything else
yes i'm not sure why they needed to uh
gauge their opinion because pretty much
every healthcare practitioner in the
country is screaming
at the government to bring back just
some basic controls controls in the
first instance which would inconvenience
people at all it is no inconvenience to
put a mask on when you get on a tube or
a train but people don't do it when i
get on the tube i'd say maybe 10 to 20
percent of people are wearing masks it's
idiotic if you go to europe everybody is
and levels of infections are much much
lower there's plenty we can do to
protect each other and and christine
wales has the highest number of cases
but also has the strictest measures when
it comes to mask wearing doesn't it
yeah in wales i mean there are obviously
lots of other factors and uh deprivation
is generally one of them and also once
it's rife in a community obviously it
spreads more and the number of
infections goes up so masks won't do it
on its own but it's a simple thing we
can all do other things that would help
which europe generally doing france
germany um austria italy are vaccine
passports or test passports doesn't have
to be a vaccine but you know we all use
an oyster card when we get on the tube
why we can't just flash our phone and
show that we are either doubly
vaccinated or clear of covered to go
into something i don't know but if not
it will have to be working from home
which apparently is going to have the
biggest impact
yeah um and ali um
where do you where do you stand on plan
b is is it inevitable that more
restrictions are going to come in do you
think
well hopefully not and i think that the
the government is seeing that the the
way to avoid plan b is to ramp up the
the booster shot regime and that's why
uh there's a lot of pressure jeremy hunt
came up with this proposal to reduce the
time lapse between your second and third
booster jab from six months to five
months which is something that boris
johnson seems to be also in favor of uh
so i think that's really the focus and
this is also being reported that now
under 50s are going to be allowed to
have their booster jab after christmas
so i think the government's very much
seen that as the route out of this but
look um it's keeping all options on the
table we just don't know how it's going
to evolve uh you can see certain
councils liverpool council has already
broken ranks yeah encouraging people to
work from home but the government has
going to look at this in the round it's
also going to keep in mind the effects
on the economy here as well okay we've
got to head to a break uh stay where you
are uh coming up we'll discuss a story
that's on the front of the sunday
telegraph family to accompany the queen
to all events is there headline talk
about that and more in a couple minutes
[Music]
welcome back christina and ali uh still
with us um christine i'm gonna let you
start with this because i know you'll be
spitting feathers over the front of the
mirror
[Laughter]
so i'm just gonna let you go 21 tons of
hot air
what implication are you making there
jonathan about hotel
certainly uh uh prime minister is very
good at hot air he's produced huge
quantities of it over the years i'm
surprised it hasn't led to global
warming in itself and that's just from
his mouth um yes he's been jetting all
over the place in a private jet over the
last couple of weeks which is not really
the message that uh he should be sending
in the run up to
cop 20 gosh i forgot what it's called 26
what cop 26.
26 and then i had the 21 tons of uh of
carbon dioxide he's emitted from his
private jet in my head and i must say i
don't know i sort of feel like this
awful sense of looming embarrassment
with cop26 i i really hope it will be a
success obviously because i i don't want
the world to come to an end and i don't
want global warming to kill off the
planet and i am still british even
though i'm dying of embarrassment about
it at the moment and i don't want it to
be a complete failure but whenever you
hear our prime minister talking about
how marvelous everything's going to be
and we're going to have this green
revolution and then you get the the kind
of budget figures coming through showing
that about three people are going to get
some subsidy to change their boiler and
that leaves sort of 66 million who won't
and you realize that glasgow is kind of
awash with rats and rubbish and all
kinds of things and that president xi ji
ping is not coming and putin is not
coming it's hard to imagine that it will
be a huge success and that would be a
yeah
yeah okay i knew you'd have something to
say about it um ali let's get you let's
get your comment quickly on this i mean
the frustration for us is that we don't
have number 10's response so we'll try
and get that for the next hour um but
either way it's not a particularly good
look is it
look i think the optics are unfortunate
but i do actually think that the
government is very serious particularly
boris johnson himself
is very serious about climate change i
mean you've had three different uh
documents coming out of the government
in the last few weeks on climate change
you had the net zero uh plan last week
you had uh the
the net recovery plan from the
chancellor you had the heat and building
strategies there's a lot going on but i
do think that there's a serious concern
and a bit of a division between certain
members of the cabin it looks like alok
sharma is getting a little bit upset
that boris has been over egging the
pudding about how important this is
going to be and and and
really ramping up the rhetoric on on the
cop 26 meeting uh but you've also then
got the potential issue of president xi
of china not turning up and the indians
saying that they still want to use coal
for many many years to come so it's not
going to be easy but i do think that um
it is an important thing for the
government so i wouldn't dismiss it i do
think it is a close to the top of the
agenda okay we'll find out more of
course in the coming days and finally
i'm sorry you're embarrassed about being
british christina it does does upset me
a little bit but here's something to be
proud of and that is uh the queen
um 95 years old uh resting up at the
moment but the telegraph saying that her
family are going to accompany her uh to
future events so that if she does have
to um take some time out that whoever
she's visiting won't be disappointed
well i do absolutely adore the queen i
will say that i'm a massive fan of hers
i think she's she's a symbol of
everything that's good about this
country or used to be good about this
country in that she has this incredibly
strong sense of public duty and she's
also i think a very lovely person but
she you know she is 95 and uh to be
working the kind of hours she works at
that age is quite extraordinary i think
it's a shame that the palace has been a
bit
veiled this week a bit guarded about
what's been happening because i think
you know people appreciate openness and
it's fair enough for the queen to uh to
be tired or even to need tests but i
don't think they should try to cover
that up and i think it's a good idea to
have members of the pub of her family
with her in future so people all right
we must leave it there christina ali
thank you both very much and